Tell us a bit more about how this sort of chip hybridazation works
for people who are unfamiliar. I hear chip, and I, well sometimes I
think potato chip. But I, I know in this case we're probably talking
about something more like maybe a computer chip. How does this work exactly?
>> Yes, the chip is really a glass slide that contains
an array of DNA. And those, and the DNA is bound to glass beads that
are scattered on a regular pattern on the, on the chip. So then that DNA is
designed by us to bind to the parts
of the genome we're interested in. It's a process
I talked about a minute ago and it,
it comes together through the process of base pairing
just like double helix space pairing. And then
either you have, let's say, an A at position,
the position we're interested in or G. And
depending on which of those two you have, will
either light up green or light up red on
the chip. Have a specific position on the chip.
>> I see. So you essentially have sort of a
discrete, or, or quantum unit for every little DNA molecule
that you're testing. You get a little signal that says,
oh, you have an A, or you have a G here.
>> Exactly. And because humans are diploid, you'll also get situations
where you have A and G, one from mother,
one from father. So then what we see at that
position on the chip is red and green or
kind of a yellow signalling you can think of it.
>> Oh that's really clever. So that allows you
to easily distinguish any given position that you're looking at.
>> Yes. So when we get the data at 23andMe we actually can plot it on
a simple x y plot with the red on the y axis and green on the sorry
on the x axis. And then we'll see three
clusters of people who are AA, AG, and GG, because
those are the three possible situations for this position
in your genome. Then we can say, well if you're
in this cluster. Just because the process is called
clustering, and you're AG, and if you're in this cluster,
then you're AA. So there's a kind of a
simple analysis problem at the end of the output there.
>> I see, and it sounds like you're
actually using, sort of, the information from a pooled
set of individuals. You know, you're sort of looking.
So even though an individual call may be difficult
to know where on that graph you're, you're place
if you use this clustering like you said you
can more readily identify oh, you're part of this
group so you're AA, not AG kind of thing?
>> That's exactly right and there are also situations you
can imagine where we get even more information. So you
could imagine a situation where you have a deletion of the part of the
genome we're interested in. Then what we'll
see is a new cluster, another cluster
[UNKNOWN]
three, with lower intensity. Because there's less signal there because there are
fewer DNA molecules. So then, a new cluster could emerge. And it
could be as infrequent as one in 10, 000 people, or one
in 100,000 people. But we'll see a little nucleus of samples there.
>> Now in in lesson two of our course we actually talked for the first time
there about the idea of base pairing and
we learned about the base pairing rules and
how things fit together. What I find really interesting
is the idea that in a double stranded DNA
you know of all these letters matching with each
other is, is what you're telling us the idea that,
a single nucleotide variant is just one letter change
here, that if one letter doesn't match, then essentially
what's happening is that the strand can't actually hybridize
completely, it can't base pair completely, and that's why you
you don't see the signal for one, but you
do for another. Is that essentially what's going on?
>> It's something very close to that. So what we expect is that
all of the letters leading up to the letter we're interested in will bind.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And like you say, if there is a an error there, one difference, then it
won't bind or it will bind weakly. So the signal will be weak. But then the
specific letter we're interested in, which will kind of come out one more base.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Has, there's a pool of As, Gs, Cs and Ts floating around that
can bind there or not. They'll only bind. If it's the correct base pair.
>> And it's unoccupied.
>> And it's unoccupied. Then we'll see
the the extension happen. The reaction that leads
to the color, you know, the color that we can see in our imaging system.
>> That's great. So essentially you have this,
you said the chip is a slide, and you're looking at
a million bases in this one little chip? This one little space?
>> Yeah, so there're even more than that.
There are more than a million beads per chip.
Because, it's better to read the same variant many,
many times just to get a good average signal.
>>
>> The reason for that is that, if
you're in the corner, maybe you'll get slightly different
optics because the camera's looking at the center of the chip or
so on, or something like that. So you just want some redundancy.
>> I see.
>> So it's more than ten million beads per chip. And that process has
been improving over the years. The density
of the chips has been increasing a lot.
>> How many chips, so, I mean, do you, have
you always used the same chip, or how do you
make changes. You know, if there's a new, I guess,
I don't know, a new trade or a new a
new SNV that you become interested in, are you able
to change your chip so you can look at that?
>> Yeah, so we update the chip approximately every 18 months. we're on the
third iteration right now. and we're constantly looking for new variants to
add to the chip to improve the performance of it. So you can
imagine that if there's a paper published that says, this mutation and this
gene causes a disease and it's, you know, it's very interesting to
find that out. We can design what we call a probe for
that, just the base the sequence of DNA that's attached to the
glass bead, and make sure it's on the next iteration of the chip.
>> You mentioned that the hybridization process is sort of
the, the longest part. so that happens over, over night?
>> Yeah.
>> What, I mean for those of us I mean, we've learned
conceptually about base pairing, but any technical insight you might
have. I mean what's Why is this an overnight process?
>> Essentially, it just takes time for the DNA in your
saliva, in your extracted saliva sample, to find the right feed. So
you want to give it time to just search around in the
solution, find the right bead, and bind there and that takes time.
>> I see.
>> It takes time, just based on how quickly
the DNA moves around and how tightly it binds.
>> and what do you use to measure the results? Are you, I
mean, are you just like snapping a
picture of the chip? What's actually happening?
>> Yes, it's very close to that. in essence, you get what's called
a fluorophore attached to the, the bead. Because of the presence of the
A or the G at that position. that's the red or green signal. You,
you shoot a laser at it to excite the fluorophore. And then you take a
photograph of it with a digital camera. So a lot of it is very
much, you know, digital camera based, which
is interesting, that that technology with our technology.
>> Yeah that, and it also sounds like. I mean, I know how big
my digital camera picture files are that sounds like it's a lot of data,
a lot of information that you end up with
>> Yeah. So all of that data from
this giant image files gets processed by software that's
actually run at our lab in Los Angeles and translated into the x, y plot that I
mentioned before. Because for each bead on the
chip, really all we're interested in is how much
red is there in there and how much
green. The photograph itself is not terribly useful after
we've extracted that data.